well Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has reiterated his
government's plan to retain security
control over Gaza after the war ends
let's get more with hamda salut she
joins us now live from occupied East
Jerusalem hamda good to see you again
what more did uh prime minister
Netanyahu have to
say Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu essentially just reiterated
the three goals that he has for the war
and additionally he spoke about what the
Israelis are hoping to do after he said
that he wants to create a demilitarized
zone inside of the Gaza Strip and the
only Force who could be responsible for
that are the Israelis he said he didn't
trust any sort of international force or
coalition to get the job done for him he
also mentioned that there were
significant military operations today
inside of Gaza both in jabalia and in
Han yunes in the South the Israeli Army
has said that they've completely
surrounded the southern city of Kan
yunes and are operating in the heart of
it all while trying to deepen their push
into Northern Gaza while continuously
making gains according to them the
Israeli Army released a statement
earlier saying that they had achieved
many objectives listing battalions that
they say they've eliminated but they
have not provided any proof or evidence
to those claims the Israeli defense
minister yoav Galant traditionally
speaking at that press conference saying
that the issue of the captives is very
important to the Israelis and remember
we just heard from the Hamas
spokesperson OS Hamden who said that the
Israelis need to stop the aggression on
Gaza in order for there to be more
captive deals but the Israeli defense
minister yoan Galant has been saying for
not just days but weeks that any future
negotiations are only going to happen
under Fire so there are different
interests obviously
as this war continues more than 60 days
on
Meen and ham we understand there's been
more fighting on the Israel Lebanon
border what details are
emerging an intensification of the
exchanges of fire in recent weeks on the
Israeli Lebanon border and uh we have
been hearing from the Lebanese Armed
Forces saying that an Israeli shelling
ended up killing a member of the
Lebanese armed forces the Israeli
military issuing a rare statement
acknowledging that they did it and
apologizing saying quote we were working
to neutralize a tangible threat that was
identified and the Lebanese Army was not
the target going on to say that the
Israeli military is sorry for the
incident and it will be investigated
this is the first statement of its kind
since the War Began we haven't seen any
other statement like it even though
there were civilian killed in southern
Lebanon and three journalists as well as
Israeli aggression in the southern part
of Lebanon continues as well maleen
thank you for that Hames salut there for
us in occupied East Jerusalem